what is today's video today's topic the
gender weight cap somebody sent me this
video said watch it Alba and I want to
show it to preach so hit the play button
play up women in the United States and
in Western Europe are the freest and
most liberated in human history in any
ways they are not merely doing as well
as men they are doing better women's
emancipation is one of the glories of
Western civilization and one of the
great chapters in the history of freedom
so why then are those in the women's
movement such as the leaders and members
of activist groups like the National
Organization for Women the professors
and Women's Studies departments at our
colleges and many women in the media why
are they still so dissatisfied these
better did you notice that [ __ ] ugly
pair of glasses you know I didn't Batman
shades like the [ __ ] like the about
to get wings right here these feminists
hardly acknowledge women's progress yes
they concede that some advances had been
made but the fact that most women reject
their activist brand the feminism and
think of themselves as free is for this
crowd proof of just how entrenched
patriarchy and inequality truly are
women are so oppressed they don't even
know it consider the issue of the
so-called
gender wage gap how many times have you
heard that for the same work women
receive 77 cents for every dollar a man
earns alliant this charge is constantly
repeated by feminists activists and
their supporters yeah yet it is so
deeply misleading is to border on
outright falsehoods $0.23 gender pay gap
is simply the difference between the
average earnings of all men and women
working full time it does not take
account for differences in occupations
positions education job tenure or hours
worked per week now wage gap activists
and groups like the American associate
no right there that's it that's where it
gets good university women or the
National Women's Law Center they say no
no even when you control for these
factors women still earn less well it
always turns out that they have omitted
one or two crucial data points take the
case of doctors on the surface it looks
like female physicians are clearly
victims of wage discrimination they
appear to earn less for the same work
but dig a little deeper beneath the
surface and you find that women are far
more likely than men to enter lower
paying specialties like Pediatrics or
family medicine than higher paying
cardiology or anesthesiology they're
also more likely to work part-time and
even women who work full-time put in
about seven percent fewer hours than men
women physicians are also far more
likely to take long leaves of absence
usually to start a family now there are
exceptions but most workplace pay gaps
narrow to the point of vanishing when
one accounts for all of these relevant
factors now how do the women's advocacy
groups react to this they insist that
women's choices are not truly free women
who decide say to stay home with
children or to work fewer hours or to
become pediatricians rather than heart
surgeons are held back by invisible
barriers or internalized oppression
according to the National Organization
for Women powerful sexist stereotypes
steer women and men toward different
educational training and career paths
and family roles but is it really social
conditioning that explains women's
vocational preferences and their special
attachment to children perhaps in the
pursuit of happiness
men and women take somewhat different
paths and isn't it more than a little
patronizing to suggest that most
American women are not free they're not
self determining human beings and here
is common sense proof that the
male-female wage gap is untrue if it
were really true that an employer could
get away
paying jill less than jack for the exact
same work but most employers fire as
many of their male employees is possible
and replace them with females and enjoy
a huge market advantage as a regular
campus lecturer I routinely encounter
students who have fully accepted the
feminist propaganda American college
women are arguably the most fortunate
liberated beings on the planet yet in
their feminist theory classes they're
likely to learn that they are put upon
and tyrannize by men and the more elite
the school the more advanced the degree
the more likely they are to take such
feminist propaganda seriously but this
doesn't have to continue the time has
come for young women to take back
feminism reform it correct its excesses
repudiate the victim propaganda get rid
of the women are from Venus men are from
Hell storylines begin the arduous task
of correcting almost three decades of
feminist misinformation women who are
plagued by workplace injustice or sexual
violence will be best helped by truth
and solid research not by hysteria and
hype and as a final piece of personal
advice for young women appreciate and
make good use of the unprecedented
freedom that you have i'm christina hoff
sommers of the American Enterprise
Institute for Prager University
ok girl
[ __ ] she reminds you of porn star that's
it hold hold hold up god yes I'm Toby so
you serious Olympic porn star that looks
just like who okay I'm gonna put up a
picture and tell me you don't look like
those in the lighting not really yeah
she kind of does a little like a lot yes
they do okay now I realize it was super
insensitive and like on this topic to do
that but I couldn't stop thinking about
it do you think you're less viewers did
on matter that viewers know more okay be
[ __ ] Alister okay so all the topic of
this video um I think she raised a lot
of great points about how a Chinese a
lot of week and I think especially when
you're trying to push an agenda for when
you're trying to push a point for it if
you're using supporting evidence that
it's false and that's the monster bleah
false that's an issue hold on hold on
hold on listen Dre fans we're not saying
that it does not exist that we still
don't have steps to do and we did
everything is kosher and everything is
nice that's how we're saying so don't
even try to go in there and saying like
chill we're not saying that but she
brings valid points yeah she does very
valid and I've always felt off about the
we've got cousin working government jobs
working in the military my experience
has been the opposite the women have
been killing it most of the workplaces
are filled with women women are
dominating domini in some fields I mean
if you look at ITT is still dominated by
men but in general you guys yeah you gay
hey go boo boo do you and yeah I get
that women and men look for different
things and happiness I didn't know if I
agree with that
I specifically would
very much I certainly know a lot more
women who wanna say we hate kids
why do we hate kids total cuz we hate
keys wait why though cuz he just like
this no it's cuz we like money that's
why I stole it okay Nina Harvey on the
screen over there killings okay all I'm
say was thank you Christina summers I
know her real name
oh nice Thank You murderers okay if you
disagree with what she said you need to
tell me that your face was fiction i
this woman china you shield okay so
those do you guys think if you disagree
with what she said you know leave your
comments below i explained why they talk
about [ __ ] alright so that's it for
today's video if you guys like that be
sure to LIKE subscribe facebook youtube
we don't put everything on facebook
because YouTube's our main bits follow
us on Instagram all that good stuff
we got a patreon page so if you want
don't need a little bit money you know
give us a little thumbs up then we do a
little I definitely went the wrong
direction job but that's yes so you know
thanks holler a dollar makes me holler